they're training there these kids by
chasing them of course or so yeah I know
they're just following them just keep
running until I stop nation even though
this is a creep movie everyone still do
the rap you bet both impression begins
my living dragon son some reason I wrote
this movie to creat two official
trailers right here from the MGM channel
people before we do that I wanted to say
thank you to everyone who's been
following us on the Stardust app ladies
and gentlemen this is not a sponsored
video by Stardust making that clear they
should sponsor all our videos those
gonna shatter they're not quite a bit
over there we do 30-second reactions for
TV shows films trailers oftentimes you
know maybe once a month maybe a few
times more thing might just make a
little 30-second sketch it's been a lot
of fun a lot of big youtubers over there
as well cat quiet the links in the
description box follow us first porfavor
because we love posting over there would
love to have you become part of this
stuff we don't have a word for it it's
false in Stardust yeah
goodnight love nothing really matters to
him right now
including me do you know NASA KITT I'm
taking the fight
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
[Music]
[Music]
- we'll be in debates for so epic I know
right
[Music]
Oh see that Rockies here you learn more
about yourself when I stepped in every
wasn't all about me oh yeah
I wonder which point in the movie that
line comes from oh man I've seen all the
Rocky movies several times a Creed I
unfortunately only watched the one time
yeah and I loved it let the big impact
on me yes if there's one instinct I have
though but you got to do with sequels
apparently all the time written darker
and more desperate go yeah talk about
that sense of despair what I really
liked about this trailer though was that
it didn't seem to entirely lose its
sense of what makes this franchise so
endearing is it's hopeful qualities
because even though it's like as it was
escalating towards the end of it it was
going back on those themes of not giving
up persevering pushing through you know
all the things Stallone likes to preach
in his awesome screenplays and it was
really being communicated though in such
a physical matter that's what the rocky
franchise does sometimes it's very on
the nose sometimes it's a lot more
subtle in this trailer I love that the
examples they were showing us all these
inspirational tales and like things you
might hear about a motivational speeches
or personal development talks were being
shown that those are most applicable in
the darkest times so I actually really
like this darker approach and I don't
know how everyone will feel towards the
darker approach for me personally I'm
like it's easier to you know feel these
qualities and sometimes I could sound
kind of corny from a script there was
like Rocky three through five it's
pretty corny those qualities of rocky
what makes this franchise such a
standout in its inspirational tale is so
present here in such a tartlet film
who's that you know yeah I don't think
this is too far of a cry from the first
one because the first one is a pretty
intense drama but yeah I mean a
different
does look I mean the first see they show
kind of made me flashback to that Jason
Bourne movie where he's like out in the
desert like dog fighting and stuff I
mean that's part of the fun of the rocky
franchise is we're gonna flashback you
know cuz cuz rocky 4 has all those
juxtaposed training montages where
Rocky's out in the snow doing it the
natural style then Drago's in the gym
with all the machinery and stuff part of
that made me think of of that movie you
know harken back I don't know where
that'll fall in the context of this but
yeah I mean it seems like they're very
smart about just figuring out a logical
progression for these stories to go
because at least yet it doesn't seem
like they've gotten into later rocky
territory with the brothers trying to
take this it seems like it makes a lot
of sense even the gimmick of having
Drago's son come back just seems like it
would make sense given Creed's story and
also I like the stuff they're touching
on with the fact that now he does have a
lot to lose words in the first movie the
whole point is he kind of doesn't you
know he's on his own and he's kind of in
the shadow of this guy he never really
even knew and now he's got all not only
his legacy but he's got his girl and a
kid and he's got rocky and all that
stuff and everybody seems to think and I
wouldn't doubt it for a second that
rocky might not make it through this
movie so this seems like it's gonna be
pretty heavy I don't know I think the
movies gonna hem with Creed dying and
then Rocky's gonna get right a good yeah
we're gonna get Rocky Balboa part two
and that's gonna be an epic film that's
what it's all been building to entering
actor the guy who plays Ivan Drago is
kid I don't know who that dude is but I
do know he's a real-life boxer he's a
real-life boxer and kickboxer okay Mac
is when he was like it I was like this
guy's a beast look at him he's a beast
yeah I feel like this movie is gonna
really succeed in its town or at least
that's where it has to most succeed
because you know when I see photos
stills of Ivan Drago and rocky 4 it just
kind of laughs cuz Ivan Drago but then
when you see Dolph Lundgren if you
thought he was scary and imposed
when he was young and buff and blond an
advanced vacuum now I'm like oh man
wrinkly Dolph long me not scary that's
appeared pissed off like I'm so happy
I'm happy about my past
hey you know what it looks like from
this movie because there's barely any
Rocky
in this trailer which i think is really
smart because when this movie was first
announced I had a lot of criticisms
about what I was hearing - oh it just
sounds like it's becoming a freaking
Rocky film again he got I haven't
dragged rose kid back in here like geez
what this was really bringing me back to
because rocky 4 is so much about Ivan
versus Rocky inventions for Apollo and
montages yeah the best part of that
movie was like eight months these three
montages separated by two CS when you
got this storyline here with Adonis
Creed one might think that oh this when
you first hear about this story that I
was another Rocky tale but actually the
way they're directing I'm like oh wait
no uh v'c or sits more of a personal
tale for Adonis Creed that was his dad
who died yeah granted he didn't know him
but now that he's still he still has to
make his own name even though like he
made his own name in the first one he
still has to make his own name with this
fight like this is the way to prove it
even though Ivan Drago is all like
jacked up on steroids and science or
robotic the kid here looks way more
scary kind of like what happened before
and I thought it was it kind of
interesting to have Rocky's presence in
this trailer mostly be him trying to
talk him out of doing this yeah you know
which just seems kind of a turn for him
as well part of me wants to make a Cobra
Kai joke and be like huh maybe we're
gonna get to see things from Drago like
Ivan Drago side the rocky side see
they're both just guys trying to do
better than they did yeah yeah they have
to have some kind of confrontation
between rocky and Ivan in this and I'm
excited for that - I mean it's not the
focus obviously but you know I'm yeah
yeah definitely excited to see them
confront each other because I have to
imagine that they've both aged and even
if they're super at odds you know I
can't imagine it's gonna be the exact
same kind of exchange it would have been
you know however many years ago thirty
out of years ago I'm really hoping
because I like Tessa Thompson
the first one I feel like she does a
great job I feel like she elevates that
material a lot the writing on her I
thought was okay I think here though you
know they're flashing I mean yeah she's
a lot more famous now cuz you got kill
Marvel Ravagers to love ya from the way
it looks I mean her character looks like
she's grown a lot because what is she
and the first one she's like an aspiring
musical artist or something right yeah
and now she she's like a mom she looks
like her character has matured a lot
give up those dreams I'm wondering if
she's gonna be more in the Adrian role
that served rocky well for so many years
yeah I mean right now everything we're
getting at like how when you see I
haven't Drago it looks scary and
imposing not ha he's back like he looks
pretty intimidating and also it's color
palette looks different too it's got
this like really dark blue thing going
on about it yeah a little more I guess
seems like all the the shadow to lay
ratios are a lot harsher and yeah it
just seemed like a lot more visually
dark anyway guys are you excited for
Creed to is this how you're gonna spend
Thanksgiving with your family let us
know in the comment boxes y'all you guys
can subscribe please to the reject
nation click that notification bell to
get notified when one of our vids is up
and hey you can check us out at patreon
we got TV show reactions and q and A's
and follow with some the studs that link
in description box the review rejects